i want to talk about elon musk though
let's go let's jump over to this article
from the post millennial um twitter
employees triggered by elon musk buying
ownership stake and platform elon musk
is now one of the largest shareholders
this we know and we have a collection of
tweets from
andy andy noe did all of this reporting
cassie nick rumbaugh a data scientist is
among the employees and contractors very
upset saying a prominent transphobe
buying a large stake in twitter is not
at all funny i think it is yeah it's
very funny
i'm honestly kind of terrified right now
you see the the reason why i don't
respect you cassie because you literally
have nothing to fear because elon musk
isn't going to do anything to you not
only not i mean we're sitting here being
like i doubt elon will actually even get
anything done and you're like i'm
terrified of what of some guy who lives
far away from you you've never met
before who was going to do nothing i
just
if these you know you know what i'd be
more worried about i'm more worried
about a wasp coming through the window
yeah because sometimes those wasps they
climb through the edge of the window
those are still those white socks and
protestants breaking it yeah i know so
that's right they got the gin you know
they're just getting drunk over there
here we go
we've got uh gerard taylor says my
current sentiment stock is up yay but
what about our company culture pronoun
it's one guy they all have the pronouns
maybe as he's on the board of directors
once a year he'll come in and vote on
stuff and the day-to-day operations will
be run by other people he's going to be
one guy voting on the board there he's
not going to do anything dramatic he's
going to go to the other investment
companies and say
look if you want this to make more money
and you want to fix the platform you've
got to give a little bit back you're not
going to see trump you're not going to
see alex jones they're going to keep
their misgendering policies but they're
going to do little things here and there
little titty little little little
tidbits like the babylon b will get
reinstated and conservatives will be
like yay and then we'll be like see look
now people are building confidence in
the platform coming back you had truth
social you had getter you have gab you
have all these platforms trying to
compete parlor you need to stop that
elon's gonna be like here's how you do
it and very little will change in my
opinion i hate that those are all
copycats too though like i hate that the
so-called conservatives never have new
ideas it's not a fresh type of social
media it's literally here let me copy
and paste twitter and then have our own
version of what we're going to censor
and then you know hope that we're
successful literally just steal
it yes twitter's idea and also not offer
anything on our platform that would get
regular people to want to use it yeah i
mean there's nothing
there's no appeal to these websites
other than this is where conservatives
can go and what's the point if we're
only talking to ourselves it's like
there's a big stadium yeah that's really
the interesting thing too is why would
you migrate over to these other
platforms you know the thing with
facebook i keep wanting to get rid of
facebook but my whole family chat is on
facebook and so it's like if i want to
know when the reunion is i have to
stay on facebook and find out um but i
do think that it's key to have something
new like you guys were talking about
when it's like if you're gonna invent
something
new in an existing space
um
you have to have a reason for it and
none of these reasons these are like
ideological reasons that but they're not
operational or aesthetic reasons yeah
well it's hilarious because oftentimes
conservatives will look at something
that the left has completely dominated
and they'll go oh man the left created
this new thing that they then ended up
exerting disproportionate control on
how can we do that i'll tell you by
inventing a new thing you then exert a
disproportionate amount of control and
that control can be in favor of free
speech rather than banning left-wing
people but they completely missed the
point because as you said what we need
is innovation yeah and i think also
zuckerberg and dorsey probably didn't
start off as leftists i mean
the default uh as they were coming up
and doing whatever they were doing and
going to school the default was leftism
so that's that was there zuckerberg used
to talk about freedom why does anybody
want to be on twitter why does anybody
want to be on twitter for what reason do
you want to be on twitter to hurt other
people's feelings or maybe have your
feelings hurt
for
uh
reason conservatives want to be on the
platform is because twitter is the space
where prominent
uh politicians personalities journalists
are sharing ideas it's where a lot of
ideas originate the problem is the left
has no interest in conservatives or
libertarians or post-liberals for that
matter so there's literally nothing you
gain from me on the platform other than
talking to people who already agree with
you the left can go on twitter and say
something conservatives will see it
liberals will see it conservatives go on
the platform and say something liberals
never see it that is kind of interesting
isn't it so there's literally no benefit
to anyone associated with libertarianism
civil libertarianism lib like true po
like liberalism not the woke garbage
there's no reason to be on the platform
there's going to be some high-profile
journalist who's going to be like i need
to go on tv and cry because people were
mean to me and it's like that's funny
because like the new yorker the new york
times
the new york times and msnbc don't talk
to us about the fact that we've been
swatted seven times or had the bomb
squad called to our house
me tweeting that does nothing to affect
the corporate garbage world that i no
longer care about you don't think you
have a lot of liberals following you i
do yeah but like my point is
conservatives libertarians moderates
have no influence with the establishment
and they're not going to on any of these
platforms so why care about being there
if you can't get your followers on other
platforms well then you've got a
cultural problem well then you'll be in
an
echo chamber though because if you go on
gab you're really twitter is already an
echo chamber that's my point i think you
get more you have like a bigger spectrum
than you would on gab though i wouldn't
know because i've only been on gap for a
couple of weeks but what i saw there
wasn't you know as politically diverse
or you know there's even there's more to
twitter too than just politics and on
gab and these other social media
platforms it feels like it's solely
focused on conservative politics and
then it's the most extreme of them too i
feel like it's the same thing that
happens once you like
redline a dis or not red line where you
gerrymander a district and you make them
more red and deeper blue then you're
just going to get more extreme
candidates who are willing to pander
harder but this is part of a larger
problem which is that conservatives only
have politics right politics is the only
sphere of our culture in which
conservatives have any stake or any int
or like any you know ability to affect
any change
conservatives don't have a stake in you
know publishing or the arts or anywhere
else and so that's the bigger issue that
has changed i'm working on it it is
changing and you know that's interesting
and conservative counter culture in the
arts i think is a movement that's about
you know that should be about aesthetics
it should be about interesting work it
shouldn't be ideological
and the work that currently exists on
the left side of the spectrum is
entirely ideological and it's
ideological at this point by design so
what we need to do is work you know to
like have good content which i think you
know you guys are both doing that is not
political and that has and the leftists
more bearing on cultures yeah the left
is producing more and more ideological
garbage that people don't because it's
shitty and nobody wants to watch it
exactly well
there's there's two big things happening
with with liberal arts
not the college
and it's that one there's a severe lack
of talent
um probably due to the fact that
meritocracy is out the window for these
people so when you are hiring people for
like the sake of your ideological points
you're going to get someone who's never
done the job before has no talent doing
it but that doesn't matter because
everyone should have an equal it should
be equity so everyone should just do
this job it's very obvious when these
people have this ideology where it's
like take the tools from the farmer and
give it to the farmhands oh no they
don't know how to farm and then everyone
starves to death that that same
principle applies to every other
industry
but the other issue is just that
when
when it you've got a lack of talent but
also a desire to inject ideology which
doesn't work no it makes bad art it
makes very poor work a great example is
you know the kind of garbage i watch so
um i thought you're about to say freedom
tunes i was like why you gotta come at
me that way she's looking right at me i
have a really good example right in
front of me
except for the fouchy episodes i don't
need to hear it if you look at the star
trek stuff it used to be good and now i
haven't watched a lot of the new star
trek but i do watch red letter media
talking about it and then i sort of like
dip in a little bit you know what the
news it's a disaster and it's all
ideological and it's like there's this
affirmative action higher uh on the new
picard
and she's terrible what do you mean
um raffy is this one character but how
is that there's a i don't know so she's
very stupid and it's sort of impossible
to believe that she could have gotten
into starfleet oh well i mean that's
just but
that's like a a plot choice right about
a character so poorly done you could
make very poorly done sure sure the
bigger issue i have is
picard is uh um the one of the first i
believe the first follow-up to the 90s
series which is which ended with deep
space nine and and since then all
they've been doing is prequels why
because we are culturally stagnant yes
so thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you